Bob abrir my friend from Sports
Illustrated he was kind enough to talk
about the NFL draft a thon an hour
trying to raise as much money for
charity to fight kovat 19 and provide
some relief for those who need it he
wrote about it in his mm QB and Albert
Brewer joins us two days before the NFL
Draft right now how are you Albert
I'm doing good I promise I'll proofread
better next time it's okay I can't I
can't you know I can't leave well enough
alone Chris as you know plus I like
making people's lives better of course
me right sure and plus if not you who if
in plus for those who are constantly on
deadline in writing like Albert they
need somebody with a University of
Michigan diploma to proofread for them
and be their own personal spellcheck
come on Albert you knew when they
postponed the spelling bee too I think
that's what he's referring to okay yeah
there were a couple of spelling well you
know and so I I texted you Albert and
you fixed it so it's all good man that's
what you get when you interview me for a
column I'll read it I'll proofread it
and I'll always try to help so two days
before the draft where are we on the job
ro front there's still nothing afoot
right this is gonna happen he's gonna go
to the Bengals and he will be wherever
he is holding up a Bengals Jersey or a
hat in his home quarantine with his
family perhaps that's what's gonna
happen Thursday night right last month
and you fortunate enough for him a
couple of his best friends from high
school were twin brothers who were tight
ends for Ohio University and just
finished up there and so he's had a
couple guys he's been able to throw -
over the last few weeks and just sort of
keeping himself in shape and everything
else I there aren't gonna be any
surprises here I can tell you going all
the way back
so really since the combine the Bengals
have maxed out the allowable time with
Perot and you know everything's been
with borough up until now it's really
been more geared towards getting him
ready to play quarterback in the NFL you
know he told me that he sort of tried to
use being the first pick or the
presumptive first stick to his advantage
where he's not as worried about
pro days or getting ready for the
combine or any of that he's just really
focused on getting himself ready to play
in the NFL you know my understanding of
these meetings that he's had with the
Bengals and they're allowed you know
three one-hour zoom meetings every week
haven't really been geared towards
getting him ready to be the quarterback
for the Bengals so yeah I mean unless
all the biggest smoke screen we've ever
seen Joe burrows gonna be the
quarterback of the Cincinnati Bengals on
Thursday night and any chance Washington
turns the number two overall pick into a
who wants to a who wants Herbert or that
is just still so up in the air it's
gonna be chase young ten minutes in and
then we move on to that question for the
Lions right I remember talking to
somebody the combine is very close to
Tehran reservists and mark it down in
sharpie he's taking chase young second
overall so I think that's been the plan
all along but I'll give Rivera and Kyle
Smith and the guys their credit I mean
no really the idea here was to make sure
they had a full idea of the landscape so
that's why you look at to uh you know I
talked to somebody there who said we
just need to make sure we're not passing
on Michael Jordan here and then you know
I think the other benefit you get from
from kicking the tires on to uh is that
maybe you smoke out an offer from
somebody who gets a little long come on
you know of course then you maybe light
a little fire under join Haskins and so
think sort of the plan all along has
been to take chase young second overall
which I mean could wind up really doing
for them what Jackson supposed to did
for the Niners last year where you have
all these first-round picks and
defensive line group and you know a
generational town comes in and sort of
puts it over the top I don't expect any
surprises I think as we expected going
all the way back to January its burrow
its young and then the tracks really
start to three well
we're here on the Rich Eisen show suss
out for me where the the - a question
mark comes from is it all the hip it's
got to be because for years to years he
looks off the safety in the national
champion game he wins it he wins the job
from Jaylin hurts and then now here we
are after a year and a half of everybody
basically saying how special this kid is
it's now time to draft him and you're
hearing some people say oh not all that
and as a matter of fact you know I mean
lower body injury after lower body
injury after lower body injury and now
here we are in the world of kovat 19 and
doctors can't physically look see him
over and so teams are gonna get scared
off and then half the other people are
saying he's still the bomb so what's
going on here
I think it's taping special in fact the
only question I mean I stay by from
people I've talked to you know I mean
there's the same arm strength question
that you have with Perot but really as
far as how he played the only question
that I've really heard is well he had
great players around him you know so
what's it gonna look like when those
windows are a little smaller and he's
not throwing to a group that's so much
better than 90% of the players they play
against you know and that's Jerry Judy
and Henry rugs and Devante Smith and
having two first-round tackles and all
that different stuff but yeah I mean the
injuries are really the question it's
not just a hip regice tune of injuries
he got hurt in high school you know he
had the two tightrope surgeries on his
ankles that's a new surgery so you don't
know what that's gonna look like five
six years down the line and then there's
the hip on top of it where you're not
truly out of the woods as far as the
blood flow issue until you get nine to
12 months post off and so it's just it's
the it's the full picture of everything
that he hasn't been able to stay healthy
and the other thing here rich - I mean
it's easy for us to say it's bad luck
but if you look at history over the last
ten years - Maurice and I know we've
been over this but every single
quarterback who came into the league
with significant injury history and the
first round got hurt again and Bradford
and ten Locker eleven Griffin and twelve
Mariota and 15 once and 16 Watson and 17
all of them carried injuring history
into the prose all of them got hurt
again his prose and so you know the
thing about it is rich when you draft a
quarterback that high in the first round
you're literally tying your livelihood
to the guy whether or not you make it as
a head coach they're not you make it as
a general manager is literally tied to
that person and so you have to look at
everything and the injuries are
certainly a part of the picture with you
I okay so now the Lions are on the clock
at three we're now 48 hours away this is
so exciting like we're two days away the
speculation is now at a fever pitch as
well as the the answers are so close to
actually being provided Lions make this
pick what do you think or they trade out
would love to get out I would love to
move down and so you know I didn't have
two players and one is Ohio State Corner
Jeff Okuda the other Auburn defensive
tackle direct brown so do you think
they'd be comfortable taking it three
but they'd rather get those guys at five
or six and they would take them at three
and so you know they're doing all this
they trying to drum up a market for the
tech you know again I think the
consensus has been that there's really
four league defensive players in this
draft and if they can trade down let's
say the dolphins or chargers then they
would still be in range to get one of
those guys and so I don't think it's
that they don't like the guys that are
sitting there I think it's just they
don't the valued be much better if they
got those guys a couple of picks later
down the line and we were able to add
some capital on the back end
where's Isiah Simmons when the guy ran
at the combine and performed the combine
it was insane and we all know what he
looked like when the chips were down in
January so where is he right now you
know like that I mean you really have to
have a plan you know you're not gonna
line them up as a traditional linebacker
you're not gonna line them up as a
traditional safety and you know to be
fair a lot of the same questions were
about Derwin James when he came out and
we saw with the Chargers moving him
around what they were able to
so there's a waited but you just have to
have a plan with him and so you know I
the perception going into this process
which was really interesting was that
those three Patriot teams the tape
Patriot connected teams the Lions the
Giants and the Dolphins would all have a
way to use him because those defenses
like the movable pieces I just I don't
get the sense that any of those three
are gonna take them even the Dolphins
who I think could wind up passing on a
quarterback of taking a tackle I just I
think he could wind up slipping just a
little bit and to me I think the floor
for him would probably be the Cardinals
at number eight so I don't think he's
gonna fall too far but I just think this
question of what you do with them
and how you use him it is an important
one and if you're a rebuilding team
sometimes it can be hard to have that
like first piece of your rebuild on one
side of the ball or the other be a guy
who maybe you don't have a defined plan
for Albert Brewer here on the Rich Eisen
show so let's say it all goes chalk that
everybody picks in the spot where it'll
be Detroit picking and they go with the
guy that everybody every mock draft is
essentially had going to them since the
minute the the season ended and then
Darius Lee gets traded so everybody
slots a CUDA in there and then fourth
overall you got the Giants they take
either maybe Simmons Brown or they get a
protector for for Daniel Jones
none of them are the reason why I'm
mentioning this is our name tool or
Herbert dolphins go five what do you got
for me 48 hours from the draft Albert to
me or a pressure point there where you
hear some stuff that they could take a
tackle and maybe come back and get your
love later Wow besides I think I think
it's been a point of the discussion in
their organization I think the idea of
even waiting into other years come up
the problem with that is you've got to
be bad again right you know what I'm
saying like and that's a tough pill to
swallow if you've already done it once
where like if you're saying okay we're
gonna wait till 2021 well you're gonna
have to be the worst team in the league
to get Trevor Lauren
because I don't think anybody's be
trading out of one next year correct and
you know you're probably gonna have to
be bad to get any of the quarterback to
the top of the draft and so I have a
hard time swallowing the Dolphins is
completely passing on a physician and I
think if they do stick I think they
would take Justin Herbert over to I
can't find anybody who thinks they're
taking two but I have that little kind
of nugget there that maybe they take a
tackle on because they can get Jordan
love later on so definitely some moving
pieces with them at five and then of
course at six with the Chargers who I
think would be in play for two I think
would be in place I'm Herbert and you
know again another team that you look at
and say maybe they take a tackle at six
so there's a lot of smoke out there on
both those teams but those who are
certainly sort of the pressure points
for the perfect position let me make
sure I heard that correctly you Albert
Breer Sports Illustrated Albert Albert
Breuer mmq b al abrir have not spoken to
a soul in the last 24 or 48 hours what
have you didn't add that time for him
I'm throwing that out there
you haven't spoken any of anybody who
thinks the Dolphins are taking two at
five if they if there's a choice between
two and Herbert you know is that correct
but I can just tell ya I mean I've
talked to people who know people who've
gone through that building I just I
cannot find anyone who thinks they're
taking two and again this might be the
world's biggest smoke screen and maybe
it's Chris squares intention to get that
out there so they won't so they don't
have to trade up but I'm just telling
you like I like like everything that
I've heard as far as that quarterback is
pointed away from to a tongue of aloha
and you know III the one nugget I can
give you here sort of interesting
I've heard that Justin Herbert has a fan
in that organism oh that is Steven Ross
Dan Marino oh I've heard of him okay
well it's better than laces out ray
Finkle what what is what about Moreno
walk me through that one well I mean I
like I you know he's he's done you know
he's sort of tangentially involved in
everything else and so sure
you know I he was he was part of you
you know he's sort of like jumped into
the process it had done some work at the
Senior Bowl and obviously Herbert had a
really strong senior bolt week and so
I've heard that he likes Herbert so
that's sort of an interesting nugget
there I III think you know part of it
for the Dolphins of course is you know
sort of looking at their three
first-round picks and knowing the
reality is that Joe burrow is not an
option for them right like you you see
you look at the picture of it and you
know I think part of it is they know
they have to fill their tackle need and
how do you view to his medicals and then
how do you view Jordan love versus
versus Justin Herbers interesting the
way all those pieces that move but I
have not I have not talked to anybody
who thinks the Dolphins are taken to
again that might mean they're taking him
wealthy hmm Wow Chris Brockman could you
imagine if any happens on Thursday did
you imagine how fast the Chargers get
their pick in what do you think is that
is that is what is that a proper
supposition that the charges would would
be all over - on the spot I would I good
as anybody at keeping his cards close to
the vest and I I have a harder time
taking them you know it's just with that
like you know you hear they like to the
medical as a point of discussion
you know Herbert is obviously could be
in play and they might have to make a
decision on him and you know I you know
I've also heard that they'd like to fill
their tackle need but I mean the one
thing they'll remember but you you know
my mom's gonna go off I think later
today have them taking - UH one thing
that's sort of interesting is that they
pick hi in the second round - and so the
Chargers could actually move back into
the bottom of the first round if they
wanted to to go and take care of the
tackle need there and so yeah I mean
it's it's fascinating rich because you
know the closer we get to the draft you
start to hear more of this you know buzz
around both those teams ticking at five
and six they really take care of their
tackle need and it's hard to decipher
what's smoked and what it isn't but you
know III think it's certainly you know
you you look at the makeup of the class
and sort of have you can poke holes and
in every quarterback who's not
named Joe borough and we're gonna have a
lot of intrigue on Thursday night I bet
Albert Brewer here on the Rich Eisen
show what are you hearing about the
rumor of my next guest john lynch
trading one if not both of his
first-round picks and so and and who
would be the ones moving up what are you
hearing about the big moves that could
be made on thursday night out of the top
ten yeah I mean the way the Niners draft
picks sort of set up they got the two
first rounders you don't have a two they
traded that for deep Ward and they don't
have a three or four those went to
Denver in the Emanuel Sanders deal and
so they'd like to fill in that gap that
they have I need rather trade 31 than 13
but I think they're open to both and so
you know I I think really sort of this
is an organizational thing and you know
that organization rich they're
everything they do very very well
thought out and planned and you know
this is all sort of part of this plan
that they put in place what that's rated
DeForest buck it was one of their best
players they wanted to build up some
draft capital they knew they weren't
going to be able to keep both Buckner
and Armstead and so they chose to keep
the guy who cost a little bit less
traded the guy who had a little more
trade value that allowed them to keep
Jimmy Ward their safety also and now
they're resetting sort of their
financials because they know what some
of the guys they have to pay they may
get a little top-heavy over the next
couple of years so they're gonna need to
have young talent on the roster so
they're gonna try and accumulate some
picks I would say a couple of things to
watch with them like Henry rugs would be
one name to watch who you know I've
heard they like a lot why not and then
the left tackle the left tackle position
would be another Joe Staley
they're expecting them back but they're
eventually going to need to replace them
so I'd watch that position with them as
well and as far as other teams that are
going to move Detroit of course is one
that could move down I would I would put
the Raiders into that group too as a
team that's maybe looking to move down
and fill that second world round hole
three teams looking to move up Atlanta
Tampa and Denver and keep an eye on the
Jacksonville Jaguars at nine they may
not only move down they may wind up
moving smash
- 2021 I've heard some teams around the
league sort of refer to them as quote
unquote The Trevor Lawrence team that
may be doing now what Miami was doing
last year fry and set themselves up to
get their quarterback in 2021 Wow okay
so that means then why would they hold
on anga coy certainly winning Gok way
and Tony Connor just making this even
uglier
on Twitter what's going on right I mean
and that would make sense about getting
getting four net out just like cleaning
it all out and that would also mean that
they would not that they would not go
after cam or Jameis or if Andy Dalton
does become expendable in the next 48
hours for the drafting of Baro go in
that direction right right and I think
one thing I put my column last night
that I thought somebody just sort of
floated this to mean it would take a lot
of doing because you have to get Yannick
signed and everything else but I mean
how about this if you can't get a
first-round pick for Yannick
what if Yannick is part of a trade down
right so say and I'm just going to throw
this one out there say tamp or Denver
wanna tackle okay so maybe you package
Yannick with the ninth pick you trade
them for whatever it is 14 or 15 right
and then you get the next year and then
you've added a one kind of your your
your more chats for 20 21 I could see
them doing some creative things there
again like the Dolphins did last year to
where they sort of recognized they put
themselves in this position from a cat
standpoint where it's really how it's
been hard for them to do anything in
2020 and so maybe 2020 becomes their
sort of clear the books year and they
set themselves up for 2021 or maybe
they're drafting high enough to get the
quarterback in the future and they've
got a lot of other picks to put down
around them this stuff albert Breer of
Sports Illustrated joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show a few minutes left
I've got again John Lynch coming up in
about a half an hour or so what did you
hear about the mock draft and how that
went down yesterday Albert
I were some technical difficulties at
the beginning always less clear was
whether or not it was on a team side or
the league side I actually heard the
words like some issues with like muting
and unmuting and that's pretty relatable
for me because you know the zoom
meetings for the Microsoft meetings
right I've made that mistake a few times
myself over the last few weeks yeah I
mean I heard it was like a little bit
rough at the beginning but they worked
through it and part of the reason it was
rough at the beginning was the league
through a bunch of trades out there to
start with so like I'd heard for example
like there were some hiccups when the
Cowboys made a mock trade with the
Bengals don't anybody think that that
means the Cowboys are trading up for
Jill Burrell I don't want anybody think
that run with it but but their bids
there were some hiccups there early on
and then once they got past that I heard
it was fine after that like the
technology worked fine and everything
else and so there's just I think there
were some like a little bit of like a
like let's get used to this early on and
I think the we had to throw some
curveballs in there there were a few
issues early on but it felt to me like
having talked to people in the aftermath
that you know once they got through the
first half hour so things were pretty
smooth and so the guys I talked to at
least are are confident that the
technology is okay the one thing that
they're a little kind of iffy on is are
the truck needs gonna be smooth and how
often is the league gonna have to stop
the clock to facilitate trades but other
than that it sounds like it went okay
because okay so from your conversations
whoever was in charge of the mock draft
to get everybody together through this
entire process in the deep end of the
pool by not just having Cincinnati
select Joe borough they they went ahead
and had a team down in the 20s try and
pull off a monster huge trade for number
one overall and see how that worked with
teams communicating with each other so
what they did like I heard like the
first few picks they were throwing
trades out there and okay how do we deal
with this how did we deal with that you
know I guess I guess what you're saying
we like Julio Jones trade it's like you
know what what you could you could crawl
before you walk but I understand that
that won't it that might not happen if
the Bengals decide to pull off the huge
trade at the very top you got to get
that out of the way I guess that that
would be the ultimate shocker that you
have to prepare for that as soon as the
Commissioner steps up to his basement
podium and says you know I've put in a
load of laundry the Bengals are on the
clock you know that at that point in
time anything can happen so yeah I guess
they went complex right off the bat and
if somebody I'm serious if a general
manager is sitting at home you know
again telling whomever you know what
what groceries are needed and they
forget to mute their phone and Jerry
Jones is trying to talk to Mike Brown
that might be difficult I I can kind of
pick that up about but we all heard
there was a bandwidth problem I don't
know what that meant I'm not an IT or an
a/v expert but you know that's what we
that's what we were seeing on time I
wonder how much of that like I don't
know how much of that was muting issue
and I I don't know like that part of it
I don't know I do know this though I
mean they're gonna be a lot of people on
there I mean the way it's gonna set up
is they're all gonna be in Microsoft
teams meeting and again like I don't
know what the capabilities these
programs are offhand or anything like
that but you know my understanding of it
the way they're gonna set it up is that
each team could be able to designate
three people right that are gonna be in
this Microsoft teams meeting I don't
know how many people even have involved
but if you do three times 32 that's 96
so it stands believers there will be but
Oliver well over a hundred people in
that room and so you know certainly
that's something that I think was
something they want to work through and
the reason you have three from each team
of course is because well what happens
if someone's internet goes down right
like you want each team just have
multiple backups so that's part of it
and then all that but alone it can be
backed up by a conference call that I
did that these guys are going to be on
and you know each team's gonna be able
to do just like designate one
decision-maker and that person is gonna
have an IT guy on hand and so they built
fail-safes into it but
I mean I certainly think there's a
bandwidth issue I again I don't know
enough about computers right I do know
this like the more people that are in a
room the more would slow it down I would
think more issue you might have so I
that was sort of the idea of having the
mas draft was to put everybody in that
room and see how it worked out all right
last couple quick hitters for you Albert
I appreciate the time
how many quarterbacks go first-round
Thursday night I'll give you the over up
the over-under a four and a half you
take the overly under oh I'll take the
under on that you will say three and a
half that's where I would set it I would
say the crowd says three guys don't
expect to go will go even if to us flips
a little bit and then Jordan love I
think is 50/50 so I would say right now
I would get out take the under on four
and a half but you'd take the what on
three and a half would you do there I
mean over just because I think I'll take
the over just because I think like if if
love is available when you get down to
and I can't I can't find teams that
they're really over the moon for him but
of course like if you weren't you keep
that quiet I just like if they were yeah
like I I would think like if you really
loved him that much and you were at the
top of the second round you might want
to trade into the bottom of the first
round so you can get the fifth year
option on him and so I I would say over
but I think Jordan loves a real close
one it sort of reminds me of DeSean
Kai's are a little bit a few years ago
wherever you want to assume yeah that he
was going in the first round but nobody
really was like head over heels for him
and so people are fighting into the
second to the middle of the second round
like that's sort of what this feels like
well sounds like for you what you're
saying and then I will say goodbye to
you and send you off into your good day
that tour might be close enough within
hailing distance of the Patriots and
Jordan love might be on available when
they're on the clock
Thursday night is that possible possible
and wouldn't it be wouldn't it just be
what would happen rich is that Bill
Belichick gets to a chunk of Aloha and
then he's healthy for 20 years
oh yeah I mean just and justice Brady
healthy for 20 years and Bill's gonna be
wanting super bowls into his eighties
that's exactly what's gonna happen
Albert burry you called it you called
your shot thanks for the call Albert
appreciate it appreciate it best to
everyone in your family be well sir
right back at you that back at you the
Talbot prayer
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here